I just kind of have a different view on
it I just think they liked the party
life I just think it was fun you know
what I mean like okay maybe
how many girls do you really know that
are really climbing the corporate ladder
I mean you maybe you think you lived in
New York right I did yeah maybe you knew
more of them but most girls I know just
have average jobs and most girls in
general have average jobs they're not
climbing anything I know a lot of girls
that are trying that are trying to
compete with men like in the cities and
I grew up with a lot of them that were
like I want to be the manager I want to
be the CEO I want to be like that's
that's a sign that I've been successful
in life and they they forward having
children for a really long time in order
to do that so I think they exist this is
just I'm just saying by and large the
average salary is like 35
000 a year for women so like by and
large women aren't climbing the
corporate ladder like there are some
right maybe like 10 15 but I would say
like by and large it's more just like it
was fun